[Música]
un muerto 17 heridos dejó una serie de
apuñalamientos ocurridos en la madrugada
de este domingo en la ciudad británica
de birmingham la policía no vincula los
sucesos con terrorismo y se centra ahora
en hallar a los autores del hecho
calificado como incidente grave
en mali dos soldados franceses miembros
de la operación marcan en el sahel e
murieron en un ataque con bomba esto
ocurre cuando el país sigue en medio de
las conversaciones para la transición
del poder mientras tanto el depuesto
presidente ibrahim boba caretta partido
de los emiratos árabes para exámenes
médicos en lo que podría ser el inicio
de su exilio
y la pandemia está lejos de ceder en
brasil se cuentan más de 4,1 millones de
contagios y 126 mil fallecidos sin
embargo el país vive una reactivación
sin distancia social en río de janeiro
las playas están llenas y el sao paulo
se retoma la actividad
una feliz mañana de domingo mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 vamos a iniciar en
el reino unido- porque en birmingham
hubo un ataque con cuchillo a varias
personas una serie de apuñalamientos
ocurridos en la madrugada de este
domingo que según la policía están
relacionados pero no los vincula con un
caso de terrorismo en una comparecencia
ante la prensa el superintendente jefe
este braham dijo que los esfuerzos se
centran ahora en hallar a los culpables
al sol solamente decir que una persona
ha muerto por las heridas que recibió
otras dos personas permanecen en el
hospital gravemente heridas y aún están
siendo atendidas como resultado de las
heridas que sufrieron durante este
ataque otras cinco personas recibieron
lesiones relativamente menores algunas
de las cuales han sido dadas de alta del
hospital y todas fueron tratadas por
lesiones relativamente menores último
ventures y para conocer más detalles de
lo sucedido vamos con nuestra
corresponsal en el reino unido- marcela
gutiérrez
marcela buenos días para usted y le
pregunto cuál es el estado de los
heridos
muy buenos días hasta ahora sabemos que
murió una persona siete heridos dos de
ellas de gravedad un hombre y una mujer
hemos escuchado hace unos momentos al
superintendente del jefe que asegura que
no fue un ataque terrorista pero sí un
ataque aleatorio esto significa que hay
un sospechoso de esta serie de
apuñalamientos en la ciudad inglesa de
birmingham hay una investigación que ha
abierto la policía por homicidio por
asesinato la zona está acordonada en el
centro de la ciudad de birmingham
sabemos que es la segunda más grande de
inglaterra después de londres así que
hasta estos momentos la policía está
recomendando a la gente mantenerse
alerta a seguir su vida cotidiana pero
mantenerse alerta porque esta persona
este sospechoso está fugitivo aún no ha
habido arrestos y en un principio se
sospechaba por el alcance de los
apuñalamientos que
han sido enfrentamientos entre pandillas
sin embargo esta mañana la policía de
los west midlands ha dicho que se trata
de un solo individuo un sospechoso que
salió a realizar esta esta serie de
ataques en el centro de la ciudad donde
hay muchos bares y restaurantes ya se
podrán imaginar la cantidad de gente que
salió el sábado por la noche la
madrugada de este domingo a divertirse
ahora que las medidas de relajamiento se
han se han hecho mucho mucho más se han
relajado las medidas de descongelamiento
gracias a usted marcela y esperamos de
tener más información en lo que avanza
la mañana vamos a cambiar de tema en
noticias de malí fallecieron dos
militares franceses de la operación
barkani por la explosión de un artefacto
casero contra el vehículo blindado en el
que se desplazaban esta misión moviliza
a más de cinco mil soldados contra el
terrorismo en el sahel paralelamente
inicia en el país el segundo día de
consultas entre las fuerzas políticas
llamadas por la junta militar para una
transición de poder después del golpe de
estado que el 18 de agosto
la salida de ibrahim abu bakr key está
en el poder desde el 2003 13 el líder de
75 años inició un viaje a emiratos
árabes unidos- para exámenes médicos
pero se cree que podría iniciar así su
exilio del país
es fácil
el objetivo de este taller es que los
participantes validen el mandato
elaborado para asegurar una comprensión
común de las expectativas de este
acontecimiento histórico el programa del
comité nacional para la salvación del
pueblo es claro y preciso se trata de
contribuir a la reconstrucción de
nuestro país mediante la garantía de la
continuación del proceso democrático
en américa latina brasil continúa como
segundo país del mundo con más contagios
y decesos por el kobe 19 el gigante
latinoamericano ya confirmó más de 4,1
millones de diagnósticos positivos y más
de 126 mil muertes a causa del brote
pero esto no es impedimento para que los
habitantes visiten de manera masiva las
playas de río de janeiro ni para que la
ciudad de sao paulo se reactiven mar y
aclara calle nos cuenta más en este
informe
el sábado las playas de río de janeiro
estuvieron casi tan llenas como antes de
la pandemia aunque esta ciudad fue una
de las más golpeadas por el cob y 19 en
brasil los días de sol han llevado a los
brasileños al mar el viernes fue el día
más caliente en río desde febrero con
37.6 grados celsius y además los
habitantes de la ciudad dicen que ya
están exhaustos del encierro
y nadie puede soportar estar en casa por
más tiempo es difícil la pandemia ya
lleva más de seis meses y nadie puede
aguantar más
por ejemplo yo tuve el kobe y me mejoré
no tuve síntomas casi toda mi familia lo
tuvo se recuperaron nadie tuvo problemas
de todo así que ya no hay manera de
quedarse en casa
sao paulo también regresa poco a poco a
la normalidad el viernes en la noche
había tantos carros viajando desde la
capital hacia las playas que se
generaron estos embotellamientos el
estado concentra casi un cuarto de todos
los contagios del país y ya lleva cuatro
semanas consecutivas con una reducción
en el número de muertes su reapertura
gradual comenzó desde julio y ahora el
turno fue para el acuario de sao paulo
y nos instalamos cabinas de desinfección
en la entrada y también tenemos un
tapete para la desinfección a lo largo
del recorrido tenemos señales de
advertencia para establecer la distancia
mínima de un metro y medio entre los
visitantes
a pesar de las buenas noticias el
gobernador de sao paulo joao doria
insiste en que no pueden bajar la
guardia y es que si bien los contagios
han disminuido levemente en brásil en
solo lo que va de esta semana se han
confirmado más de 260 mil casos en
comparación con los más de 300.000
diagnósticos positivos de la peor semana
de julio
y en francia los contagios de kobe 19 se
dispararon se registraron más de 8500
nuevos casos en la última jornada y el
acumulado de positivos se acerca a
350.000 no obstante durante los últimos
meses los médicos han descubierto nuevos
tratamientos que reducen la tasa de
mortalidad veamos más en el siguiente
informe
puede que las cifras hayan disminuido
sin embargo aún hay un flujo constante
de pacientes de kobe que son admitidos
en cuidados intensivos en francia en
este hospital al norte de marsella y
siete pacientes uno de ellos solo tiene
27 años tras meses de luchar contra el
virus el personal médico ha adaptado el
modo en que trata estos enfermos una
mujer de 81 años fue admitidas algunos
días pero no está usando un ventilador
en lugar de ello está recibiendo terapia
de oxígeno con una máscara
nos permite alcanzar altos niveles para
que la paciente tenga suficiente oxígeno
mientras las cicatrices en el pulmón
sana nos evita poner al paciente bajo
anestesia general o un ventilador que es
muy invasivo y puede llevar a
complicaciones
este tratamiento no se usaba hace unos
meses porque los médicos pensaban que
podía contribuir a la expansión del
virus pero descubrieron que esto no
ocurre
otras opciones nuevas incluyen recetar
anticoagulantes fármacos que hacen la
sangre más líquida para prevenir
coágulos también dexametazona un
esteroide usado por sus propiedades
anti-inflamatorias que ha reducido las
tasas de mortalidad en un tercio entre
pacientes con ventiladores en marzo de
abril la tasa de mortalidad de pacientes
con kobe en cuidados intensivos en
francia estaba entre el 35 y el 40 por
ciento ahora ha disminuido a entre el 25
y el 30 por ciento el virus aún puede
ser fatal pero la combinación de estos
nuevos tratamientos está aumentando las
posibilidades de que los pacientes
sobrevivan y eeuu conmemora este fin de
semana el día del trabajo un feriado que
este año es transversal a 100 días de
manifestaciones contra el racismo desde
la muerte de georg floyd el 25 de mayo
en mineápolis asfixiado por un oficial
las protestas que inundaron el país y
que denunciaron más casos de abuso
sistemático contra los afroamericanos
continuaron anoche los focos de protesta
fueron portland en oregón
louis
en kentucky donde fue asesinada abre on
a taylor en marzo y rochester en el
estado de nueva york donde murió
asfixiado por una bolsa anti escupitajo
daniel bruch cuyo caso ya está en manos
de un gran jurado
hasta aquí el informativo quede con
nosotros ya volvemos con más en france
[Música]